євросоюз мій номер диверсії якого ти
постачання природного газу аджі газпром до
секунд керму і майже витрати
європейському ринку, а в деці крайності
дну Європи та монополістом на і більше
щоб стали стовпами незалежності
енергетики вид політики старий ми
пережили kenko вражений місця ж маза
розвідкам краї за в Україні і знаємо про
excel але так як рейза може бути по
середньому play ноти на b стеку поставок
енергоресурсів до Європи у стратегії
нерф bespeco єврокомісії доїться і про
диверсифікацію дерил енергії на приклад
Європа травня на мерс більше ти закупили
скраб даного природного газу
засіки здорової та криптограф
єврокомісії розуміють ставку з літр
досвіду та на проведення енергощит одних
технологій
там у євросоюзу на хоті нарощує
імпорту газу з Росії експерти
сумніваються у необхідності проекту
первинний шлях до 2 століття в Європі
фактично Петро і малюка не матчі на але
of tanks проект технічний шлях 2 було
розроблено для того, що pas touche
отаманша газу обидва в залі пари стати
поста chateau і року Європи транзитом
через Україну
ланцюга роду 7 політичний проект дай-ка
ви євро поставити одну суть еротично
тому що аналітичних думав про нас той
малої ж ду три молоді і я справно скоро
ти
1 закласти відру це від сайт проекту суп
orochi такі матері виноситься за
відтінком експерти з ресторану
єврокомісії мені майбутньому майбутньому
газпром свої ділянки на європейському
ринку
не страждати